QQ Music has been continuously pursuing breakthroughs
I think this is the reason why it has been so popular for almost a decade
I'm Abao, lead of the Android platform group
Every breakthrough is inseparable from
the support of creativity, R&D, and platform
so our team has been paying close attention to
Google's technological evolvement and updates on Android
and strives to let our users enjoy the new system features
as soon as possible
Our team led the current version adaptation
of QQ music for Android 9
I'm Shawn
the engineer responsible for Android 9 adaptation
We began to pay attention to the behavioral changes
and new features from DP1
and officially started the adaptation since DP2
New features such as edge-to-edge screen support
and native system notification style
have allowed our users to feel the evolution of the platform
Especially the latter
we received a lot of positive feedbacks
from the users who had experienced the native notification
From the developer's perspective
Android Studio has also become better and more powerful
Memory Profiler makes it easier to analyze memory
and we can monitor JNI memory allocation in real-time
With the help of Android Studio
reducing memory usage has become a lot easier
Music apps usually have a foreground process
and a background playback process
To meet the background execution restrictions of Android 9
these two processes need to be modified
We analyzed the data transmission and interface calls
between the two processes
and finally met not only the restrictions of background execution
but also eliminated excessive wake-ups
In some scenarios, RAM usage can be reduced by more than 50%
We have been paying attention to Kotlin for awhile
The new features in the current project are
mostly written in Kotlin language
This brings a lot of benefits to our development:
the average number of lines of code
can be reduced by as much as 25%
and errors like NullPointerExpection can also
be reduced by around 50%
We believe that in the future
the usage of Kotlin will proliferate in our projects
With powerful toolchain and strong developer community support
we believe that Android will keep bringing us more security
better system behavior, lower power consumption
and greater user experience
With the help of an ever-evolving
and open platform like Android
QQ Music will continue to bring users
a fantastic music experience